how to talk to the man who filmed these
pictures that's Carl
Mitchell's stead can join us now on the
telephone Carl a very good morning to
you what did you see well although we
owe to begin with woke up to the sound a
bit like you tomorrow siren this morning
be quiet drinking much of it and went to
work is horrible across bollocks of
briefs I want to let them sighs solving
the smoking flame the countertops
building well and truly alike that's how
I owe it carry a camera with me shut us
up and endeavoured to get as much as
possible yeah I mean we're talking about
a major building that by the time you
saw it Carl was was well ablaze Jerry
says the building is being decimated the
room glass replaces the other half was
going through your life and we're also
seeing I mean you did a decent job with
the pictures you got pretty close I'm
not sure you can actually get this close
anymore because the police have set up a
cordon around the council building but
you managed to give us a view from
pretty much all sides of it and you're
safe any operation the firefighters are
focusing on fighting the fire time and
that the police were bringing their in
there their full capacity yeah thank you
punk anyone hearing now Kyle we're
drafting a map so we can give our
viewers a sense of perspective on this
one geographically in terms of how this
council building stands in relation to
the other two buildings which are ablaze
as well but you know the area rather
better than we do how close together are
we talking about these these three
separate buildings which are all ablaze
with these children of single powder
that was I suppose I can say what
attacked you actually the last house or
the main entrance to the council site
seeing the first cottage broke he
probably less than less than a mile away
and they understand all three 514 within
90 minutes of each other
can you rhyme guessing car you're a
local man can you recall a spate of
arson attacks in recent times is this
absolutely out of the blue any
background at all I think we're a fairly
rural town there are occasional bar a
bar that I think sighs I think generally
they're accidents but no there's never
anything like this
what